bonjour qui empêchait l offre merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
vous êtes donc en russie comment est ce
qui est perçu cette audition à moscou on
se souvient que le kremlin avait parlé
je cite d'ingérence inacceptable quand
emmanuel macron a rencontré elle se met
la nati arnaud sky à la semaine dernière
en lituanie bonjour effectivement il
s'agit d'une ingérence et effectivement
ça passe mal c'est quand même assez
normal on peut dire que la manière dont
l'union européenne dont certains pays de
l'union européenne qui soit l'allemagne
que ce soit la france maintenant qui
pourtant avait quand même garder un
minimum de retenue jusqu'à présent est
manifestement a perdu toutes limites
commencent à s'ingérer dans des
processus électoraux d'états voisins on
commence à se poser beaucoup de
questions
lorsque macron est arrivé au pouvoir
après quand même on va dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de questions sont posées sur le
plan judiciaire de l'instrumentalisation
par rapport à fillon ne semble pas que
la russie par exemple ou la biélorussie
et soutenu françois fillon contre mâcon
par exemple on ne se souvient pas non
plus de d'appel de la part de la russie
ou de la biélorussie en soutien au gilet
jaune et à la répression réel dont ils
font l'objet
jusqu'à présent donc peuvent avoir les
prises de positions de paris et berlin
pour l'avenir de minsk est ce qu un
consensus était possible ce fait la
matière noble scaglia qui remercie
d'ailleurs soit à la france pour son
soutien il est normal qu'elle remercie
la france pour son soutien puisque ce
soutien qu'elle est réellement est
manifestement de l'extérieur donc elle a
besoin effectivement de ce soutien
hamid karzaï l'osce à minsk en soit ça
ne changera rien pour la simple et bonne
raison que loukachenko réélu
que ça plaise que ça ne plaise pas
l'inauguration a eu lieu pour l'instant
titre a dans ce cas tente d'organiser de
l'étranger un retournement de pouvoir un
coup d'état et pour cela elle a besoin
de financement ce qu'elle demande et
d'un soutien direct des médias ce
qu'elle obtient également y lire 26 pays
dont la biélorussie la russie à la
chaîne
on appelait washington et les autres
capitales occidentales à la levée des
sanctions économiques
justement à part des sanctions déjà
mises en place envers différents
dirigeants biélorusses
qu'est ce que l'union européenne la
france l'allemagne peuvent faire de plus
ce qu'ils peuvent aller contre
loukachenko par exemple non je ne pense
pas que quelqu'un va envoyer une armée
en biélorussie pour faire tomber le
cachalot donc à part des sanctions
économiques et politiques ils ne peuvent
rien faire sachant que l'union
européenne je rappellerai quand même n'a
pas pris de sanction contre loukachenko
personnellement ce que prend des
sanctions contre un président élu
c'est le meilleur moyen de bloquer tout
en diplomatie internationale possible
donc
l'union européenne s'est arrêté juste
avant ce qui est assez surprenant quand
même c'est tous ces grands libéraux
démocrates et c'est qu'ils agissent de
l'étranger et qui demandent de prendre
les sanctions économiques contre le
peuple du pays qui sont censé aimer et
défendre de toute la rame de tout leur
coeur en quelque sorte en sanction du
fait que ces gens mal élevée n'ait pas
voté pour ça pose comme un certain
nombre de questions sur les motivations
derrière surtout lorsque l'on sait que
c'est un natif alaska est accompagné par
fran ac via turquie et un soi disant
journalistes biélorusses qui travaille
pour radio liberty financé par les etats
unis et qui de 2016 et 2018 ce
conseiller a été formé dans les
universités américaines
donc oui il ya une forme d'ingérence
directe sur toute l'union européenne
aussi parler de financement de de
l'opposition sous couvert dead habité
contre-coran d'un virus non pas très
bien à quoi
mais quelle quelle issue possible selon
vous ce que les positions sont figées
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans les
prochaines semaines on sait qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de manifestations du côté de
minsk ces derniers temps pour l'instant
les positions sont figées c'est une
question de rapport de force tant que la
russie tient bon du côté de loukachenko
et que lukashenko retient les leçons de
l'ukraine souviendra aussi que ça a tenu
longtemps le maiden qu'il est aussi
beaucoup personnes dans la rue et ça a
débouché par l'explosion sur l'explosion
du pays loukachenko n'a pas envie
d'exploser la biélorussie il a fait
beaucoup pour ce pays
parfois en bien parfois il a fait des
arnaques ce qui me fout rien qui ne font
pas d'erreurs
donc pour l'instant les solutions sont
figés tant que les leçons de l'ukraine
sont tenus je ne pense pas que l'union
européenne ou l'otan envisage un
scénario armé militaire
ils n'en n'ont ni la force ni volonté
politique ni la légitimité
donc c'est aussi une partie de bluff
sont quelques-uns merci thank you love
quoi pour avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou